Humana the sponsors of this next segment
is holding a special commemoration
ceremony tomorrow to honor those that
served on active duty in the U.S armed
forces during Vietnam here tell us more
is David McNeil who is the veterans
community engagement executive welcome
to the show thank you JC it's nice to be
here let's tell everyone about them and
you and I were chatting before the show
what's happening tomorrow okay tomorrow
at 10 o'clock at the Craig Road and
Decatur Neighborhood Center that Humana
has we're having a Vietnam veterans
commemoration pinning ceremony and how
did all this start okay back in 2012
President Obama signed an executive
order to honor Vietnam veterans because
they weren't being they weren't welcomed
home the way other veterans were and
because of that this is a government
effort to improve that inhuman it's very
proud to be a part of it we're looking
at some of the pictures here of past
presentations of the men and women
getting pinned if someone wants to get
pinned tomorrow and take part of this
ceremony is there still time to oh we
see one of the pins too that that's
gorgeous that's stunning if someone
wants to sign up there's still time to
sign up and be a part of this
everybody's Mark there is and there's
going to be a number on the screen to uh
for them to call into okay right and so
they need to call in they need to let us
know that they're going to be there in
order for us to be prepared for them but
what else is you have some some guest
speakers out there as well we are going
to have some guest speakers the
commanding officer of Nellis Air Force
Base uh Josh blanking on his last name
my apologies to the colonel is going to
be out there with us as our keynote
speaker and we're going to have some
other folks so this is this is a big
event taking place Marvin yes why why
Humana getting involved with such a
special calls and special ceremonies
like this Humana is a long history of
being very involved very supportive of
the veterans community
um when a few years back there is a call
for companies to corporations to hire
large numbers of veterans Ximena had
already done so as a matter of fact Q
man has over 6 000 employees that are
veterans or black spouses right so and
I'm one of those veteran employees well
thank you for your service you're
welcome um but that's the thing is
Humana has been very supportive in fact
my VFW Post my old VFW Post 983 in
Henderson meets inside a neighborhood
center on an evening okay there are the
other two in the valley themselves have
veteran service organizations meeting as
well there's there are a lot of things
going on in the neighborhood centers in
support of veterans but in support of
the community at large as well have you
been involved in one of these pinning
ceremonies before I have and what's it
like when the veterans go up there and
they receive the pen describe that
moment for us what's it like for them
it's an amazing moment and you see my my
experience I went into the military at
17 and I was raised by these Vietnam
veterans and I got to see them and hear
them firsthand what they experienced and
when you see them getting the
recognition they so richly deserve after
all of these years it can be
overwhelming it's just amazing to see
their response and I really don't know
how to describe it's just such an
emotional thing and it's I think
everybody that's able to should come out
and at least witness that part of it
yeah to see that take place or not David
thank you so much we appreciate it
Humana is holding their special
commemoration ceremony tomorrow at the
Humana Neighborhood Center that's 4803
West Craig Road for more information
call
[Music]
725-726-9112 or go to humana.com and
we'll be right back